test kitchen's virtual kitchens ghost
kitchens whatever you want to call them
they're tasty and they're popping up
across the valley yeah because they act
as a launch pad for a small business and
this morning our Candace Charles joins
us live from Tavola a new family-owned
Italian spot working out of a ghost
kitchen this one's at West Cliff and
rainbow
Candace I love this concept good morning
good morning good morning folks yeah
they're all slightly different right
your test kitchens go you try something
out your virtual kitchens you only get
to do online those kitchens really give
the chefs the opportunity to create a
whole different experience of support
they get to start a restaurant or do
other adventures and you know the devoli
business is all about creating that
unique dining experience giving you an
authentic Italian Dish to really feel
like you're in Italy and I have the
one-of-a-kind Chef Nicholas Rizzo with
me now thank you so much for joining us
tell us a little bit about your mini
this is the lunch one yeah people can
get right now right but you got a little
bit of everything here yes because we
gonna get ready to launch all their
menus okay so we have a vegetarian menus
called La Regina Verde yes and then now
we have more healthy options as you can
see like sandwiches soups and that kind
of stuff and then we have the risotto so
like my last name and then it comes with
the of course the risotto and in this
case we have a snail risotto I'm trying
to keep all the ingredients where I'm
from like the region little town and my
you know all my dreams and when I grow
up all that kind of stuff I love that I
love it you can see all of your dreams
come to life in these mini dishes here
you guys do a lot of different things
besides the ghost kitchen you guys have
classes yeah um you have specialized
experiences as well tell us a little bit
more about that yeah so of course we
have classes we do with kids adults and
a special event so I can come to your
house and I can show you dishes and you
can just sit down and cook it and eat it
or you can do it and otherwise we we
offering a private event so I will come
at your house and I will cook a three
four five six courses whatever so we
craft it we craft it in the menu as uh
the guest wants okay okay and you do
catering as well but this is this is
really the place that's helping you grow
how is it going to help grow really
quickly yeah it helped you a lot because
you can do this at all so you need like
a commercial space and then uh of course
uh you are it by yourself you don't have
a lot of people important going on
around and then uh get more focused yes
yeah absolutely this is my main cave
this is your name right now because he's
about to have a little girl yes yes
congratulations I got now he's
surrounded by all the links yes we
appreciate you thank you for joining us
this morning now he's here alone like
there's a there's a couple different
ghost kitchens in here all providing
different things and that's really the
idea you're giving these small
businesses an opportunity to continue to
continue to bring us delicious dishes
like this but this is authentic Italian
you're only gonna get with Tavola and
you can find out more about topola on
our website 8newsnow.com you can come on
down to Summerlin take out go to the
front use the QR code and order things
there or you can order on doordash or
Beach we got to cover a lot of details
of course on our website eightiesnow.com
for now from the Summerlin takeout in
the Tavo Legos kitchen